keep in mind why is patient zero right
you trace it all the way back where did
the 2.2 million come from this it came
from this guy it's that's in people that
well no no there must be something more
to it right because experts wouldn't get
it that wrong would they the guy killed
all the Sheep you guys remember a lot of
you probably have forgotten but don't
you I remember I remember when the the
death the death toll was going to be two
point two million way back yeah that was
way back what started all of this right
it was going to be 2.2 million deaths in
the United States five hundred thousand
in the UK those were the numbers that we
heard and we had to act now just in case
you think I'm making it up the British
rocked by a startling UK report warning
of a catastrophic epidemic the same
research suggesting without any action
2.2 million Americans could die if the
US doesn't take these steps 2.2 million
Americans could die Eterna Morrow who
you saw on our air yesterday he wrote
two memos trying to warn the White House
that coronavirus could cost the country
trillions of dollars and kill up to two
million Americans in this fight against
a pandemic that the White House has been
warned could kill over 2 million
Americans more Americans and died at
every war since 1776 without the strict
social distancing that number could be
as high as 2 million Americans so just
just to be clear the virus is not but
that 2.2 million number I was a hoax the
number two point two million Bigfoot
Cavanaugh rape balloon boy yeah I want
to be where did this number come from
because this was ubiquitous right this
is the number that everybody believed
and we had to act and we had to take
drastic measures because 2.2 million
right and we know now that the numbers
it couldn't be possible in the United
States if you actually look at our
demographics and you look at the media
it's not a possibility here in the
United States it could have never been a
possibility but let me introduce you to
the founder of the feast the man who
came up with this number dr. Neil
Ferguson from the Imperial College in
London he is the one again responsible
for the 2.2 million Americans will die
number here he is at
kidding you know China style lockdowns I
will now speak with Professor Neil
Ferguson director of the Abdul Latif
Jameel Institute for disease and
emergency analytics or je idea for short
beyond those smaller outbreaks one has
to adopt sort of community measures
which have been adopted particularly in
places like Wuhan and China where you
try to reduce contacts between people in
the community so why is this important
well it's important because it's a
number that we all use but there's a
real pattern here again while we're
talking about doctor I keep forgetting
his name you know what from now on I'm
gonna call him Neil for short Neil
deGrasse Tyson this guy has a pattern so
we'll start with a corona virus but this
is important because everyone has used
him they've cited him and I think this
is important to keep in mind when we
talk about the experts because everyone
says this whether you're talking about
climate change even if you're just
saying hey listen I believe the earth is
warming I believe that human beings are
considering to it I don't believe that
the Paris agreement will necessarily
change it the same case that will they
say well right now if you don't believe
the 2.2 million Americans will die well
then why are you questioning the experts
well let me present cases to why
sometimes you should question the
experts and do your own due diligence so
let's look at the corona virus numbers
he came up with a 2.2 million number and
he refused to release the workings of
the study the model is based on a 13
year old code that is completely
undocumented okay I want to be deluded
about that and you know what else this
is like the 77 cents on the dollar with
Barack Obama he is out there saying
women make 77 and you're gonna have
access to to even baby doesn't have
Google if he's in confidence could help
this guy webcrawler for crying out loud
you wonder on second why why do you why
does nobody in power have the ability to
question this number because this is the
source of the number and no one goes
okay yeah well what's your reference
there well doesn't that matter on
economies and you know that he has no
problem with it let's go back through
all of his other predictions ok
considered an authority an expert on the
issue in 2009 this man dr. Neil he
estimated that swine flu had a 0.4%
death rate based on his advice
government UK the estimated 65,000 dead
what actually happened 457 deaths the
death rate was zero point zero two six
percent so that's a little bit off bird
flu wasn't
any prediction you guys know actually I
could say that for all least call this
consists the capital of the bird flu
again dr. Neil What did he say he said
to 2005 I believe right Neil Festus I
what he said in 2005 yeah 2005 he Bertie
could 200 million bird flu deaths people
not birds people right yes people forget
the wrong bird flu sorry from bird flu I
should have I don't want to get
fact-checked by who I was screwing with
him ah Peter they're coming for you what
happened to the good work where who they
just had a few upturned noses and some
wire left from the wrench now they're
dominating world economies oh my god
drew him so the reality is there were
only a few hundred in a decade right
bird flu death less than a hundred per
year on average and keep in mind by the
way because right now they say well all
that we had a 2.2 million we even had
one hundred to two hundred forty
thousand because of the lock downs no
actually the numbers were really revised
long before the social distancing could
have taken effect and then again you can
look here at the bird flu this was done
without massive lockdowns you were alive
during the bird flu do you remember this
kind of a crash to the economy do you
remember everyone being forced to stay
in place at home another prediction it
was the you know that was it called like
the foot and mouth disease I don't know
the the the viral aaj achill
nomenclature epidemiology local I just
her foot miles these which this guy does
a lot whole food mouth so it was a he
had a model right in his imperial team
at the imperial college they suggested
millions of farm animals okay hat would
have to be killed to prevent the spread
even if at the point there was no
evidence of infection okay now what
happened animal disease experts keep in
mind experts so an expert said hey this
is going to spread we have to kill all
these animals and other experts at mom
[Music]
they said it looked like a they had a
calling it was necessary right because
the model from Ferguson well turns out
that actually it was not necessary they
didn't take into account the species
composition of farm just as someone that
I read from some kind of sort of an
epidemiological study I don't really
know what it means but I do know that it
was too late millions of animals have
been killed to cost the British economy
ten billion well actually twelve point
five billion American dollars this is
important because if you look at this
right here where they called these
animals right it cost twelve point five
billion dollars it shows you the doctor
Neil whose head comes to a point is not
he's not scared he has no problem with
destroying an economy with panic he's
done it in the past
Ferguson made another prediction on mad
cow disease had 150,000 deaths from mad
cow right this was based on the theory
back then that British sheep if you
remember this British sheep might be
capable of spreading it oh yeah now to
date there have been fewer than 200
deaths from mad cows in the United
Kingdom none of which have been
transmitted from sheep I think this guy
just hates animals so it's a trump card
and kill them and I'll show your
descendants by the way you guys we don't
have enough time to run all the clips
you can go watch the news they're
talking about this non-stop on CNN and
BBC right now they still are citing this
guy keep in mind why is patient zero
right you trace it all the way back
where did the 2.2 million come from this
it came from this guy just like the 77
cents in a dollar came from one study
all that comes from is taking the
average salary of men across all
different lines of work regardless of
hours worked regardless of education
compared it with women it's that certain
people that well no no there must be
something more to it right because
experts wouldn't get it that wrong would
they the guy killed all the Sheep this
is something that I think is important
here there is listen we had and I want
to be clear I think we all well I
actually think some of you guys here
wanted to pull me back a little bit was
like this is crap oh you did too and
actually you thought it was partially
crap but you were like let's play it
safe because we're gonna get fact-check
down there yeah yeah well I will say
that you were you were more looking back
you were more correct about how
overblown it was gonna be I was like oh
you should question some stuff but I was
definitely more drinking the kool-aid
and you were like man I don't know we'll
just check back in 60 you were drinking
my whiskey straight from the bottle
kills it
hey I asked Trump it but only prank but
if you're going to check back okay that
[Laughter]
one's the best I'm saying waterboard
bill with Trump vodka
we had these I think that when in the
absence of data it was prudent to take
some precautionary measures
sure yes when we didn't know now keep in
mind the absence of data that's what
people were reaching for numbers and
they said well to point two million and
I still think we should have quarantined
the sick you can go back and said why
don't you quarantine old people and sick
people and now people are saying that
back then people's an how you monster
listen cope take any any his store
anytime throughout history go back
through I don't know times around Christ
yeah there nope it's of non lepers or
lepers you don't throw in the non lepers
you don't shoot them separate let the
lepers run free this is what you don't
quarantine the second but at one point
we had height we had hypothetical
numbers we needed to work with these
models and as a matter of fact actual if
you go to the website we didn't work
with those models there were plenty of
other epidemiologist who were experts
who were just considered contrarians who
said this really doesn't make any sense
it doesn't add up and we tried to cover
that we just have to be careful because
big tech gets together and they will
remove videos they remove the video like
these were the names of those doctors
from Los Angeles at Los Angeles County
five million relays five million plays
they had several thousand people who
they've actually tested for antibodies
never seen the death rate 0.1% yep got
removed from Facebook because it
violated guidelines oh it's fake
according so we've had to try and be
consistent we've had to try and be
authentic but also we've had to try and
navigate Facebook YouTube Twitter who by
the way take their marching orders
directly from the World Health
Organization who said by the way not
that long ago that it couldn't be
transmitted through human to human
contact so when you're using them as
your Washington Post or Snopes or
Southern Poverty Law Center fact
checkers at what point you say you know
what maybe the contrarians are right
because it doesn't take a scientist or
an expert to have studied any virus ever
and said you know what I think that if
you start fondling someone who has it
that's a bad idea it's a slippery slope
it's a sweaty clammy slope I think what
we're seeing right now is we are seeing
the theoretical unfortunately clashing
with
the real world okay so it's theoretical
we could lose 2.2 million lives we could
now we're gonna revise it we could lose
a hundred thousand to two hundred forty
thousand right right right we could have
whatever how many tens of millions of
people are infected though that's
actually probably Alex though they don't
want a report on that now because then
all of a sudden that lowers the death
rate so we could have those but now we
have real-world data where we've tested
people for antibodies what do we have we
have New York City Los Angeles County
Santa Clara County we have miami-dade
County we have Chelsea in Massachusetts
we have a few more I kids I don't have
them off the top of my head every single
one has revised their death estimates
their death their mortality rate to zero
point five to zero point one percent and
that's including the ninety five percent
of whom are people over the age of 80
and have pre-existing conditions every
single one that has run these studies so
you can even say maybe they're getting
too many false positives or the--the
antibody tests okay
let's double it the people who said this
is more comfortable to the flu were so
much closer than the experts who said
four to seven percent it's laughable
and we have real-world data now in that
we see how many people have died we see
how communicable it is we don't know the
extent of that but by the way all
testing shows us between four to six
percent for two I think six point five
percent depending on the county that
means that far more people been affected
we have real-world data now that what is
it twenty-two million over a twenty four
million jobless claims at this point I
thought other than that it could be it
could be significantly higher than that
we have real-world data now that one in
five suicides is linked to unemployment
we have real-world data now that we've
crippled economies we have real-world
data now that 36 percent of retail
industries might not reopen after this
economy and that is clashing with the
theoretical which we know is verifiably
false but unfortunately big tech and
their overlords want to silence doctors
right now who are out there speaking to
espousing the real world observable data
at this point so at one time sure in the
absence of data I think it was prudent
to take some precautionary measures but
at this point in the face of
overwhelming data it's a conspiracy and
it's a hoax you don't have to rely
exclusively on experts sure you should
have wise counsel everybody should have
wise count
but you should also do your own due
diligence and certainly when faced with
theoretical data or real-world
observable data commonly referred to as
actual science go with the latter hey if
you like this video be sure to subscribe
if you're already subscribed hit the
notification bell hit all notifications
we have new videos that go up every day
as well as of course an entire show not
available on YouTube at ladder with
credit comm slash mug Club if you did
not like this show please comment below
and address your comments to Gerald be
sure to do that
also his Twitter